i'm very excited to be here my name is
mark allen
and this is my first strange loop and
thank you for coming to my talk
we're going to talk about some old
things today we're going to talk about
history of programming languages
and some of the issues and problems that
early
language designers sought to overcome
and whether or not they met those
design goals or not in a number of
different cases
specifically we're going to look at four
different languages today
fortran which was released in 1957
and is still around today although not
certainly not in the form that it was
released then
lisp which is also still around we're
going to talk about algol
and cobalt and then i have a conclusions
which didn't show up on my slide for
some reason
and i also have a very extensive
bibliography
that that i encourage you all to examine
because there's just a lot of great
stuff in there
some of which we're going to talk about
today and and some of which you'll just
have to explore on your own
um in any case uh um i am excited to be
here and thank you for uh for coming to
the talk
so in 1972 uh a
computer scientist named gene samut who
worked at ibm at the time
wrote a paper for the acm that talked
about
the history and future of computing
and this this quote that i've pulled um
is a really interesting one to me
because it was written a long time ago
and there was sort of this assumption i
think that maybe
that computer science would establish
itself as a as a true science in the
sense that
you know you have um experiments that
you can repeat
that you essentially can use the
scientific method on like you can expose
hypotheses and you can test them and
develop theorems and things like that we
do have those to some extent
right like there are computing theorems
that that
uh that are established sort of at the
bounds of physical reality and i think
joe armstrong talked about that really
well this morning um and we also have
other theorems that
you know we've been associated with and
the thing that comes to mind immediately
is
is like eric brewer's cap theorem right
which is a theorem
but it's not like a physical theorem
it's you know more of a software
um uh design constraint essentially
um but what she wrote was virtually
everyone agrees that today programming
is an
art and not a science and many
although somewhat fewer people would
contend that programming can and should
be made into a science
and it just made me think is programming
today
more of an art or more of a science and
that's what i'd like for you to think
about as we walk through these slides
together
also accompanying this article in 1972
was this chart
um now i know it's an eye chart and
trust me it's an eye chart even at a
very high resolution
but uh this gives you an idea of just
how many languages that were being
looked at in her article that she wrote
in 1972 and this is really
you can you can't read it down here but
this starts at 1951
and it walks all the way over here to
1971 so this is a span of 20 years
and you guys can see just how amazingly
diverse
and also sort of a convergent a lot of
the languages of those of that era
were which is really fascinating to me
in a lot of different ways
i wanted to give some context to this
diagram by kind of describing the state
of computing art before 1954.
so um the uh the first sort of
commercial computer that was available
was univac which was uh
built by the eckert motley company and
they were eventually acquired by um uh
remington rand
and after remington ran they were
acquired uh or merged together with
sperry
and they became sperry rand and uh then
eventually uh they turned into uni
uh unisys so they had this very long
evolution of company but it's still
around today
and there was a guy that worked there
named william schmidt and he wrote this
this essentially this automatic
compiling feature called shortcode
and what shortcode did was it
essentially allowed you to describe
an algorithm with uh without using
actual octal numbers that you would have
to insert
physically into program locations in
memory
and so it was a great labor-saving
device it was it wasn't exactly a higher
order language
i mean essentially you'd have a a
program that was very
compact and condensed but it wasn't
really human readable
it was still very machine oriented so we
were humans commun
communicating with machines at the
context of
machine language so it was the humans
that really had to adapt to
how machines talk to one another and
the other thing that was really amazing
at this time in remington rand
was grace hopper started working uh with
actually she she got hired at um the
motchley company
and when it was acquired by rand she she
went with it
um but she wrote the first compiler
which was called a0
and it was in 1952 which is pretty
mind-blowing to me
and the thing that was even more
mind-blowing and this isn't
excuse me this isn't in the bibliography
but she describes really clearly in a
conference proceeding called the history
of programming languages that was held
in 1978
that none of the management people at
remington uh
believed her that they essentially could
not believe that they had this program
that could
kind of take human readable instructions
somehow translate them into machine code
and then execute them
but that's what she did and that was the
program that did it um
this uh this program a0 and its
successors a a2 and a3
are going to play a part uh later on
down the line when we start talking
about cobol
in 1952 she wrote a paper that describes
some of the things that she was working
on this paper was called the education
of a computer
and she wrote this quote which i which i
quite like because it reminds me of my
day-to-day job
and what she wrote was the programmer
who has been supplied with code
he translates into instructions to the
computer until the novelty of inventing
programs wears off
and degenerates into the dull labor of
writing and checking programs
this duty now looms as an imposition on
the human brain
true that is today um so the more things
change the more they stay the same
um that's that's also a recurrent theme
in this talk
uh john backus wrote a paper uh later
much later
where he tried to describe the context
of of computing in 1954 for for
contemporaries that came along after him
um and what he wrote was that the goal
of of these early languages
was to overcome hardware limitations uh
for the most part
so in those days computers were far more
primitive as i'm sure you can imagine
and they actually omitted a lot of
features that we take for granted today
some of them for example only had
circuits that could compute ants
so they didn't have ores and so to
overcome that they had to implement ores
in software
and so they they had kits essentially
these little kits that
that allowed you to do binary ores i'm
sorry logical ores
um and had primitive input output
operations like onto paper tape or punch
cards
there was also a lot of insufficient
hardware registers so
some of the state-of-the-art computers
of the day had like five hardware
registers
and the other thing that's really cool
about
researching this was sort of discovering
how much efficient work uh was actually
accomplished with these systems of the
day
um and uh one of the things that hopper
describes also
uh was using these systems that had a
thousand words of memory and a word is
16 bits
um to uh to do computation and she
talked about how they swap
things onto tape and pull them back off
of tape and so forth it was really
really interesting
um so we had all these limitations and
there there was this
this sense of automatic programming so
there was this term that was floating
around out there
which was this idea that before
programming was this
this job where you as the programmer
would sit down with like a piece of
graph paper
much like the program that joe showed in
his keynote and he would actually
physically write out like
okay at memory address zero zero zero
eight i need to input this octal number
and then it you know zero zero zero
eight sixteen uh or sorry sixteen i need
to input this octal number and so forth
and that's actually how you would
construct your program
so what these kits would allow you to do
is sort of provide mnemonic operations
so it was a little bit more like
assembler that we're familiar with today
it had symbolic addresses right so you
could give things names and then you
could reference memory locations with
names instead of the actual physical
location
there were library subroutines so like
let's say you need to compute a square
root or something
and you didn't actually want to figure
out how to do that you could use a
library routine to do that for you
and then there was floating point
operations so if you had math problems
that required floating point precision
um then you were going to have to you
know either deal with uh
with floating point operations yourself
because there weren't there were no
floating point processors at that time
um so you're gonna have to do it in
software and you didn't want to write
that yourself probably because it's
really messy
um and actually if you want a hard
programming challenge
uh writing a floating point a processor
and assembler is is probably a pretty
good one
so if you're looking if you're looking
for a task to
take on in the hallway that might be a
good one to go for
so our story evolves to 1954 and uh
i just wanted to give some some wider
broader context of what was going on in
1954.
the president of the united states at
that time was dwight eisenhower and
the first children were being given
polio vaccines which had just recently
been invented
almost a year before that and also the
uss nautilus which was the first atomic
sub
was commissioned by the united states
navy uh so that's kind of the context of
what was going on in the 50s at least
for a few bullet points um and i want to
talk about fortran
and specifically i want to talk about
the evolution of fortran and how it came
to be
so in 1953 there was a
gentleman at ibm named dr cuthbert heard
and he's shown in this picture with tj
watson senior
who was a you know pretty big monkey
muck you might have heard of him
and he wanted to build a general purpose
uh computer for business and he wanted
to do it
before univac before rand could do it so
that ibm could own the patents
and and what he found was talking with
um
people that he worked with was that
constructing software
for these for these computers even
though they were general purpose
machines to
could do all kinds of computation was
really laborious and very difficult
and so he authorized a project run by
john backus who we're going to get to in
a second
that he called fortran formula
translator and
this is a really interesting piece of
pop culture kitsch that came in the 70s
this
this lower uh this lower picture is
actually from a board game
uh that was developed in the 70s called
fortran and uh
i just particularly like it because it
says input reason
output pleasure
that's the kind of board game i want to
play um
so uh let's talk about john backus john
backus was a really
pretty interesting fellow he was a
graduate student at columbia university
he was studying mathematics
he happened to be walking by an ibm
showroom that was in new york city
and he had saw from the from the window
he saw
a large automatic calculator which was
actually the size of probably the stage
and he came in and asked questions about
it and when the
when the person that was uh showing him
the machine
learned that he was a mathematician uh
took him immediately took him upstairs
for a job interview
they asked him some brain teasers and
then they hired him on the spot to be a
programmer
and he didn't even know what programming
is but as you can see in the first
bullet point he hated programming and
when i put programming in scare quotes
what i really mean by that is this
laborious process of
you know writing out this really long
hand way of inputting
um values into memory locations and then
actually executing on top of them
so in 1953 he invented speed coding
and speed coding is sort of this
mnemonic device like short code that
we've already talked about
it's sort of an alternate implementation
with the same idea
and then in 1954 cuthbert heard came to
him and said hey
we're going to build this new computer
and we want you to write a
a language for it that will make
programming easier for people to
address machine questions too and so he
led the fortran team from 1954 to 57
and then he invented bacchus normal form
which we're going to talk about later on
when we get to algol
and he also won the national medal of
science in 1975 and he
won the acm touring award in 1977 and uh
just as a brief
discursion here um uh the evolution of
john bakkus's thoughts about programming
languages is really fascinating
um in a future talk maybe about just
john backus
but he evolved from designing a language
called fortran which was used worldwide
and is still in use today
and kind of moved to a position where he
felt like these declarative programming
structures were really harming
the advancement of computing as a
profession and as a discipline
and he advocated in his touring speech
using something more akin to functional
programming and
more algebraic denotations he was a big
fan of a programming language we're not
going to talk about today called apl
but it is really fascinating and if
you're interested in the history of
languages
check it out it's pretty cool here's
here's some poll quotes that i have from
his paper
describing the history of fortran so
again this is giving context
of what it was like in 1954 when he
started working on a project
early systems were slow and expensive
and through experience
programmers learned sorry programmers
began to doubt writing efficient
programs could actually be automated
also some marketing departments claim
their systems
could have human level lexical
understanding of programmer intention
now does anyone here think that a
computer program has human level lexical
understanding of your intention
let the record show there are no hands
here's another quote one was accustomed
to finding lots of peculiar but
significant restrictions in a system
when it finally arrived
that had not been mentioned in its
original description
hmm where have i heard that before
now here's the quote to summarize this
whole experience
it's difficult to convey the strength of
skeptic
skepticism about automatic programming
in general and its ability to produce
efficient programs in particular
as they existed in 1954. all right so
that's where we're at on the ground
floor
people were very skeptical that you
could actually take this process
of writing things out by hand and
automating it to the point where
what you had at the end of that process
was actually more efficient than what a
human could devise with their own brain
power
so these were the design goals of
fortran as stated in his paper
first they're going to virtually
eliminate coding and debugging
we're going to make programming reliable
cheaper and faster
and it will also be an example for
others to copy
all right fantastic i'm in favor of this
now
how many of you think that these design
goals were met
no hands you're all very smart um
but but this is really interesting
actually uh they worked on this project
for a long time much longer than backus
actually originally estimated
in fact he went out on pre-sales calls
to customers very large customers
in the united states and told them that
within six months
six months they're going to have a
working system available for them to
start using
and this was in 1954. now when the
system was actually delivered in 1957
this is what he had to say about it it
will suffice to say that the compiler
produced code of such efficiency
that its output would startle
programmers who studied it
the degree of optimization performed was
not equaled
again until optimizing compilers began
to appear in the middle and late
1960s so that's a pretty impressive
achievement
now the things i wanted to point out to
you here were we didn't meet any of the
design goals as they were stated
but but we did meet one design goal and
actually maybe even two design goals
these are meta goals
one is we proved that you could take a
system
that uh could have sort of interaction
with a machine at a human level
and produce efficient programs from it
programs that would run faster than than
if a human sat down and hand wrote code
and that is pretty much still true today
in many cases
not always true but in many cases it is
true um
and he also um discovered that it was
it was easier for people to understand
how to interact with computers
from fortran than previously before
because before it was
really a very exclusive group of people
that could understand
even how to program a computer much less
make it do anything useful
so fortran really broadened the appeal
and the ability of people to interact
with the computer in a way that was a
little more natural to them than
than numbers and mnemonic codes all
right so this is another poll quote that
i really liked
it was an exciting period we were often
astonished at the amazing
transformations
which made the program efficient but
which we would have not thought to make
as programmers ourselves
so here we have a case of a system that
was built to be
efficient and is actually efficient in
surprising ways and i think
that many of us in this room have
experienced that uh effect
on our own programs so what are some of
the flaws that we had
well um specifically things that uh the
bacchus writes about as in paper were
debugging problems
one of the things that he wrote about
was this was a poll quote not on the
slide
we were hopelessly optimistic about the
problems of debugging fortran
and hence syntactic error checking and
facilities in the first distribution
were weak
and the other thing that was really
interesting to me in studying this was
the design choices that they made as a
language implementer
they didn't feel that building a
language as a
as a discipline would be difficult the
actual dis the the difficult problem
that they wanted to solve was building
this compiler that was going to be super
efficient
and overcome all the skepticism of their
peers but what he wrote later on about
20 years later was
we knew nothing of many important issues
that worked that turned out to be
important
these included block structure
conditional expressions
and type declarations so all of those
things were missing from the first
version of fortran
and even though they were missing people
and companies and customers were using
this
software language to build really
important applications for their
business
so i think that's a pretty interesting
thing too one other thing which i've
touched on before but which he wrote
about explicitly was estimation problems
i mentioned the time scale that he got
that wrong um
and uh there were other problems that
are on the slide that that i'm not going
to go into necessarily
but fortran was the first the first sort
of the the pioneering i would say
computer language
um that still lives on with us today
although
if you look at the the historical record
you'll see that the early programs bear
no resemblance in any way
to to modern uh programming that's yeah
in in the fortran family
so uh next i want to talk about lisp how
many list people are in the audience
today
cool well we're going to talk about this
uh quite a bit um it's really
fascinating
topic um but first before that i want to
do a biographical sketch of john
mccarthy
um many of you may be familiar with uh
with john mccarthy already but if you're
not
let's do let's do this brief sketch um
he essentially
invented lisp in 1959 but you may not
also be aware that he
worked on algol um he was one of the
original members of the algo committee
in 1958 he worked on it through 1963.
one of his contributions that you may be
familiar with is if then else
he also invented the term and technique
of garbage collection we're going to get
into that a little bit later
like how it came to be and why he
invented it he also coined the term
artificial intelligence
he predicted computing utilities in 1961
where you pay by the hour
which also sounds really familiar to
modern people he won the acm touring
award in 1971 and the national medal of
science in 1990.
and this is what he had to say about a
paper he wrote in 1981
about lisp which i particularly like
because i think it captures mccarthy's
uh attitude about his language uh pretty
succinctly
he says lis seems to be the second
oldest surviving programming language
after fortran
so maybe we should plan on holding one
of these newspaper interviews
in which grandpa is asked to what he
attributes to having lived to a hundred
that sounds like mccarthy to me um i
love that quote um that's from a paper
that he wrote in 1981.
um so here are the design goals that
mccarthy laid out in a paper that he
wrote in 1978
what were the design goals of lisp or
explicit what was it what problems was
he trying to solve when he came up with
lisp
um and it may is an interesting
historical note that there was actually
a
a predecessor system to lisp um that was
implemented in fortran
and it was called fortran list
processing um
and it was actually uh not exactly what
mccarthy was looking for
it built on some of the ideas that you
could have all these lists out there
and that those were really useful data
structures to do operations on and do
computations on
but they weren't exactly what he wanted
he wanted a succinct algebraic
style of expression so first of all he
wanted to enable symbolic reasoning
instead of numerical computation that's
really what fortran was focused on as
a programming language we want to count
you know compute all these things
math problems or computing proofs of
math problems
um you know computing vectors for
various engineering problems those sorts
of things
the representations of data and
expressions is lists and memory
that's one of the things he wanted to do
was be able to
prove out that a computer language could
use these data structures successfully
as
a programming language he wanted to use
functional composition
and recursion as programming idioms so
instead of writing a declarative
style of where you have explicit loops
we're going to have recursion
we're going to have functional
composition where you build up small
functions that do one thing and then
you're going to combine them together in
interesting ways and do larger things
and then finally we wanted automatic
memory management which was actually a
requirement of lisp because of the way
that
that things happened so here's some
things that uh
that arose from those things first he
introduced this idea of lambda
into lisp and this was an idea that he
needed so that he could give a function
a name
and pass it around as a proper argument
to other functions
um he writes in another paper which i
didn't
have a poll quote from but essentially
what he said was
i just needed to to have a convenient
way of naming something
and it wasn't necessarily that he liked
lambda calculus per se
but that he liked the this idea that you
could use this uh this
this mathematical term and name
something and then pass it around
um so he developed garbage collection to
deal with the erasure problem and
in parents i have this idea of there's
two operations that you may be familiar
with there's car
and cutter which basically pull the head
of the
list and the tail of the list
respectively so
when mccarthy came up with these
functions he had this problem which is
okay well what do i do with the rest of
the list i don't need it anymore but
it's still sitting around in memory
and if i'm going to compose those things
into a new list then i'm going to have
to reclaim
memory from somewhere somehow some way
and so that's how this idea of garbage
collection came to be
uh in in existence was i have all this
detritus sitting around and i need to
reclaim the memory space that it's
occupying right now
um so i'm going to go ahead and come up
with this technique that i've invented
called garbage collection
to solve that problem now mccarthy had a
student named steve russell
and he read through mccarthy's paper
called the
the symbolic computation
it has a very long title in s
expressions
and it's called part one part two was
never published
um just in case you ever go looking for
it um
but anyway steve russell hand coded this
eval function which is defined in that
paper
and he wrote in a machine code for this
ibm 704 which is the same computer that
john backus was working on
and that served as the first interpreter
for the language it may interest you all
to know that
um that mccarthy intended to have a
compiler
and we're going to get into that in a
couple of slides too
but but here's something that came out
from the eval
that implementing eval actually arose a
new interesting thing
he writes that writing eval required
inventing notation
represent representing lisp functions as
list data
with no thought no thought that it would
be used to express list programs in
practice
now to me that was a really shocking
thing to learn this idea that
the that you have this data as program
is sort of a spontaneous thing that
occurred
um not by design but actually just by
happenstance
um is is really interesting to me as an
amateur historian
um so here's some things that uh that
that mccarthy noted about the flaws of
lisp
he first said that interpreted programs
ran about 60 times slower
than compiled programs in the first
release of lisp there was no lexical
scope for variable bindings
that came later and that he planned that
the awkwardness and here he means the
number of parentheses specifically
that the awkwardness of the s expression
would be solved by the use of
m expressions do any of you have you
heard of this before
m expressions a few of you okay so there
was this idea that that
they were going to actually write list
programs in some declarative style like
algol without parentheses and that there
would be a machine translator
that would essentially take those things
and turn them into actual list programs
that would then be interpreted and
executed by the computer
but as he writes in the paper that
receded into the indefinite future
so that never happened and the
parentheses stuck around
now i mentioned before that they had
this idea of building a compiler
this is what mccarthy had to say about
that uh the fortran people were
expressing their shock at having spent
30 man years on a compiler
and it didn't seem like we could get
these graduate students to hold on
to hold still long enough that we could
get 30 man years of work out of them
so essentially the reason that lisp
never really had a compiler until much
later was that
he didn't feel like he could get his
grad students to write one for him
so this is another lovely pull quote
that i have
this is from a phenomenal paper that i
heartily recommend to you and is
of a part with what joe talked about
this morning this comes from a dijkstra
paper called the humble programmer
the humble programmer was written in
1972
and it was dijkstra's discursion on how
we need to
eschew complexity and embrace simplicity
and what he writes about lisp is that
it's jokingly been described as the most
intelligent way to misuse a computer
i think that description is a great
compliment because it transmits the full
flavor of liberation
it has assisted a number of our most
gifted fellow humans
in thinking previously unposit
unpossible
impossible thoughts let me commend that
paper to you again it is fantastic
it is very short it's about 12 pages
long and it's also available freely
and it's in the bibliography so if
there's one thing you come away from
this
talk with uh highly recommend reading
through that paper
so that's a lisp and now we're going to
move on to algol
are people here familiar with algol uh
in passing like you know you recognize
the name
okay interesting um so algol was uh
was started in 1958 there was this
specification that was mostly on paper
as far as i know it was i think it may
have been implemented into compilers
in a few places and in 1960 they kind of
met together again and decided to
do a more complete and full
specification due to ambiguities and
misinterpretations in the original
document so there was an international
team of people
um let me back up a little bit further
in um in the early 50s
a team of europeans specifically kind of
got together
and at the time computing in europe was
even more primitive than it was in the
united states
um and when when fortran was released
there was a
i wouldn't say a fear but there was an
idea running through the currents of
europe that
uh that there needed to be some kind of
uh european computing language
um and that they didn't want to
necessarily have you know
50 different ones of those they wanted
to have a single universal computing
language
and what they did is they reached out to
a group of americans through
the association for computing machinery
to
come together discuss these ideas and
then come up with a language
specification
and that's how algol actually came to be
that's that's the the origin
of the of the language itself now it's
gone through uh three specific
iterations
um there was the 58 paper there's the
1960 paper which is what we're going to
talk about today
and there was a later revision in 1968
that is uh is a interesting historical
artifact around human interaction with
other humans
there were a lot of political uh
backbiting and misgivings
about algol 68 and if you're interested
in that i commend you to the wikipedia
page
which covers it in in nice brevity so um
here's some design goals of algol and
they wanted as i mentioned they wanted
to create a language as close as
possible to standard mathematical
notation
and be readable with little further
explanation they want to use this
language for the description of
computing processes and publications
and they wanted to advance a universal
agreed-upon language without worrying
about specific implementation concerns
so at the time there were all these
computer manufacturers they all had
different word sizes they all had
different memory types they all had
different ways of storing things and
retrieving things they all had different
instruction sets
so it's basically a giant hot mess what
they wanted to do was come together and
say okay without regards to any specific
implementation
we want to go ahead and build this
computer uh language
um sort of in the abstract and then
later on we'll figure out how we're
actually going to implement it on
machine a and machine b and machine c
um and so now i want to talk about some
of the people behind algol um
quickly uh the first one from the
american side is a man named alan perlis
he was the original member of the
delegation in 58 along with
people like john backus and john
mccarthy who we already talked about
perlis is a pioneer in promoting
computer science as a discipline
distinct from mathematics so one common
thread that i found
researching a lot of these individuals
is almost all of them were trained as
formal mathematicians
he was president of acm for a while he
won the turing award in 66
for compiler design um most of which can
be drawn directly from algol
um he's also really famous for writing a
paper in 1982 called epigrams on
software
programming um which i've been widely
quoted and i now have a couple of
poll quotes for you because i quite like
them the first one he wrote is there are
two ways to write an airfree program
only the third one works here's another
one i like
some program languages manage to absorb
change but withstand progress
and there's about 200 more like that so
if you if you want to read the full deck
then you can go to the bibliography and
pull it um there's also peter noir
uh you may know him from backus noir
forum which we're going to talk about
because it was invented for algol
specifically
he was the editor of algo bulletin in
europe they didn't have the acm
so they invented this this group of
people that subscribed to this
newsletter called the algo bolton
peter nor was the editor of that for a
long time um i already mentioned back
his normal form
he wrote one of the first algol
compilers in denmark
and he won the touring award in 2005.
we already talked about dijkstra 2 but
just just to sketch a
biography of him he's probably best
known for his graph traversal
algorithm he also wrote a really
foundational paper in concurrent
programming
invented the mutex he wrote a letter to
the editor called go to considered
harmful which
as a meme sort of lives on to this day
with x considered harmful
he also wrote the first implementation
of an algo compiler in the netherlands
in 1960
uh he won the acm touring award in 1972
where he talked about his paper for that
um he's a he is a giant in the field of
computer science and
a really fascinating person um to to
read
his artifacts um and uh yeah it's uh
fantastic and interesting um so here's
some first that algol introduced into
computing science and uh
programming languages in general um
introduced recursion as a practical way
of doing programming
it introduced code blocks with lexically
scoped variables that was an
innovation they had call by value and
this thing called call by name
which is not very well understood at
least not by me call by name is a really
early form of lazy evaluation so the
idea was is that
you could define in your in your in your
procedure you could define a variable
that would only be evaluated when it was
called
um in the procedure and not previous to
that so you could delay computation of
that value until you actually needed to
to consume it
that sounds pretty familiar to most
modern ears
it was a first algol also had the first
intrinsic boolean type
it introduced a lot of keywords that you
would find familiar things like if then
else
unto for loops while loops a whole bunch
of stuff like that
and it also had the first formally
specified grammar the grammar was
introduced at a conference
in um at unesco in 1959 by john bakkus
alone
and then later peter norc sort of
clarified it and refined it in the algo
report
in 1960. this is what alan perlis wrote
about the report that they came out with
with
normal form he said that this language
proved to be an object of stunning
beauty
and neither bacchus nor any other
adequate formal semantic definition
technique was available to the algol 60
designers
we now know that semantics was
considerably more difficult to treat
than syntax
so what perlis is talking about here was
so backus came up with this idea that we
can formally define a grammar right we
can say
that this keyword needs to occur in this
position and then it can be followed by
these legal values and that has
you know some kind of meaning what he
wanted to do actually was
define formally the grammar and the
semantics
and what we've found is that it's really
hard
in fact there may not be a way to do
that and so this was an idea that at the
time was completely new to people and
they were trying to grapple with it
algo was never very popular in the
united states um
and one of its stated goal or unstated
goals but a hope of many of the
europeans especially was that it would
replace fortran
um and uh that obviously is not has
failed
um the semantic meaning of formal
grammar uh
was open to interpretation um yeah that
sounds familiar um
so it's like uh it's like how people
interpret http
rfcs um you can think of it that way
that has a formal grammar but
loosely defined semantics and it opened
new avenues of inquiry in computer
science
and i have in the bibliography a paper
that was written in 1961 that pretty
much blew my mind
the paper in short describes a
syntactically directed compiler so we
take this formal grammar
that's in bnf and you feed it into the
compiler
or into this parser and it actually
builds a compiler for you based on what
the grammar says
and this is an idea that came from edgar
irons in 1961
and was a completely new innovation that
no one had ever thought of before
and uh to know today that uh that that
sounds like a pretty modern idea
um fascinating paper um also very short
25 lines of algol actually he describes
how this would work so
good paper to look at next i want to
turn to cobalt this is the last
language we're gonna talk about today
and i know i'm running short on time so
i'm gonna have to go pretty fast through
this
cobol design goals were basically driven
around this idea that we want a single
programming language that worked across
multiple machines
that used maximum english instead of
mathematical notation
yes they actually had an argument about
whether you should have a plus symbol
and the word add
or subtract or a minus symbol apparently
people felt like
you know people that weren't programmers
would be confused by by these simple
arithmetical operators it needed to be
easy to use
even if that meant the language would be
less expressive and
another goal brought in the base so who
can speak uh problems to computers
um we'll talk about a couple of people
that i already touched on um one is
grace murray hopper um maybe some of you
are familiar with uh with her
uh she's she is also an amazing person
um in computer science history and and
uh
worthy of further study and and and uh
um talks and so forth um she got a phd
from mathematics in yale um she retired
from the navy as a rear admiral in 86.
um she famously visualized a nanosecond
it's in the bibliography it's on youtube
i highly encourage you to watch it it's
two minutes long
she popularized the term debugging when
she actually found a physical moth and a
computer in 1946
led automatic programming team at
revington rand we've already talked
about that
and she also developed this language
called phlomatic which was a major
source of inspiration for cobalt
the next person i want to talk about is
another lady named gene samut
she got an ma in math from illinois
in 1949 she worked at sperry rand
that i mentioned before with grace
murray hopper on the univac one and she
started working on cobalt for sylvania
electric in 1958 to 61.
she joined 19 ibm in 61 and developed
formack
and is also a major major reason why a
lot of these historical computing
artifacts exist today she
was very interested in the history of
computer programming languages
and did a lot with the acm especially to
ensure that those things would live on
so here's what she wrote about cobol it
was quite clear
quite clear that the disputes between
people from the same organization
were often as great and sometimes
greater than between people from
different organizations
and this applied virtually to all
organizations involved whether
manufacturers or users
that sounds pretty familiar to modern
ears here's another one
there was a strong ibm anti-ibm bias in
this committee from me and
some but certainly not all of the others
since i was not working for ibm
i can freely though not with pride admit
that in some cases suggestions or
decisions were made on the basis
of doing something differently than ibm
did it
that also sounds familiar to modern ears
here's what she writes about the
experience of
having cobalt experience with real users
and real compilers
is desperately needed before freezing a
set of language specifications
have we known from the beginning that
cobalt would have such a long life
i think many of us would have refused to
operate under the time scale that was
handed to us
now it's important to know and i didn't
mention this before but they had six
months to work on a language
specification
and they had to develop their entire
specification as a stop gap
because there were eight different there
was a consortium of eight different
computer manufacturers
and they all threatened to basically go
off and do their own thing
now they were kind of kept in line by
this short term report that issued in
six months
and the fact that the u.s government
enforced the cobalt had to work on their
systems
so here's some things that cobalt has
introduced it introduced this notion of
typed records or data definitions
it was at one point the most widely used
programming language
it's still in use in many companies
today probably to their chagrin
it met its design goal of implementation
independence and this was largely due to
the influence of government contracts
so that's pretty interesting here's a
couple of conclusions that i will leave
you with
and i'm going to have just a brief time
for questions
sorry about that so first of all many
early practitioners expected problems
related to programmer error
and efficiencies would be solved by
languages but we now know that that's
not necessarily the case indeed
it's really a human problem not a
technological problem
even when it was explicit goal to reduce
what we might term cognitive load
it proved difficult to achieve
satisfactory results in practice and i
think that's also still true today
and i would strongly recommend again
browsing through this bibliography and
reading one or two of these papers
they're really fascinating and well
worth your time
even as a very modern audience that's my
slides today um thank you very much for
your attention
i appreciate your your attendance today
thank you